did you see the project veritas release
i did not project veritas just put out a
video of
this guy who was like a democratic
operative saying
they want to get violent they want to
pull out the slicey boys he called them
spicy boys
the slicey boys are when you're dealing
with power with politicians you don't
like you bringing a slicey boy
oh boy yeah yeah yeah and project vegeta
he's got this guy saying it
i'm not gonna pretend like this guy's
the most prominent democrat in the world
but you got democrats saying this is our
plan
he's and he's what he's not i actually i
have a kind of salient thought about
this
so what was interesting to me about this
most recent project veritas release was
that this happened in colorado which is
where i'm from
and it happened in weld county colorado
so that's not interesting to most people
i know but i spent a year there
that's a farming county there's nothing
there
this isn't fort collins this isn't
boulder this isn't denver
this is way out in the middle of nowhere
there are cows there are oil rigs
there's nothing exciting or interesting
this isn't cosmopolitan
and to hear this coming from somewhere
like weld county to me is frankly
terrifying
because it's taking root there oh and
like that troubles me
in middle of nowhere country yes and
when a bunch in farmland this is
literally like corn fields and cows
i'll tell you what this guy was saying
he was saying that
basically if joe biden gets elected
they'll still riot
if joe biden gets elected and he won't
sign the progressive policies they said
he said they
we won't let him leave his house i don't
believe it
the question the question that we keep
hearing is they hate joy
of course of course but the question is
you know under which president will we
have bad riots
all of the above all of the above but
what's the difference between the two
the media will will go one way or the
other well the big the big difference
from the presidents
oh under both presidents we're gonna
have riots right yes so what's the
difference between
uh a trump presidency and abiding
presidency in that regard uh trump might
actually put some of them in jail
exactly yep yep might actually put some
of them in jail like yeah
they did go get that guy in uh portland
that's for sure yeah that was his
name the shooter yeah rhino i mean they
sent the feds after him
yeah and what did trump call it
retribution or something
that's brutal that's too much i don't
like that well a guy pulled out a
machine
right of course of course well so i
guess the official story is that he was
armed
and he was armed because he had a he's
been there's a bunch of other photos
with him being armed he was arrested
before
gunshots the report i read said that he
got off 50 rounds or more before they
they started firing on him wow man i
don't know
it's it well so i read a report that
said one witness claimed that wasn't
true
oh but i'll play this way man
no no look if you get a guy who's got a
gun charge then he comes out later in
stock the trump supporter and kills him
and then i hear from the cops that
he had a gun i'll be like i mean the
dude had a tendency to have a gun you
know what i mean makes sense i'm not
going to doubt him on that regard
makes sense to me yep the riots are
coming no matter what
i have i've thought about the supreme
court packing same sort of similar
theme here is maybe biden's really had
been avoiding it
because he doesn't want to and he knows
that the left really really wants him to
right that's what he's already said not
really like i said he's not a fan of of
course
yeah i spent the day in the horse
country today trying to get my mind out
of the news but
dude i go but i i talk to regular people
all the time
and then they tell me stuff and i'm just
like wow i can't i heard some really
crazy stories from the skateboarding
community
and this is this is one of the craziest
things to me because so when when i hear
escape let me tell you secret about
skateboarders they're nihilists
they don't care about your politics they
don't care about any of this stuff
leave me alone i'm gonna go skate
they're libertarian they're very
libertarian very anti-authoritarian and
very nihilistic
if they can live in a one like 10 people
crammed into one bedroom paying 100
bucks a month just to get by and they
can skate every day
they're happy sort of like what you got
going on here well this is this is this
is a crazy a crazy
you know this is a weird communal farm
but uh i'm hearing now all these
skateboarders voting for trump
i had i had some amateur skateboarder
amateur usually implies like they've got
some notoriety some
hitting me up being like amazing job
dude you're killing it it's amazing and
i'm like what
like this dude should not be like a
politically active person
it's kind of getting crazy the amount of
times i come across people who are
apolitical
who like i've been skating my whole life
man whenever you don't talk politics
with skateboarders i don't care
sometimes they might be like left
leaning or but they're normies they're
doing okay
that's that's that's the extent to which
they have like public views like a
public video series called do a kickflip
because it's just like there's
nothing going on it's like the 800th
video i've seen called do a kickflip
yeah and now i got these these dudes
posting
there are some crazy stories i don't
know how much i can reveal because it
might you know a lot of these people
are scared of getting canceled but i'll
tell you this man
some top musicians hollywood celebrities
and skateboarders have hit me up in the
past several months
telling me their their their trump train
2020.
even when i was saying like so this is
like before trump put out a second
agenda before i was like okay i'm gonna
vote for the guy
i had people saying like dude you're
wrong man trust me and i'm like this is
a hollywood celebrity from like tv shows
on netflix and amazon telling me
i gotta vote for trump and i'm like i
thought hollywood was far left i can't
this is crazy to me so i have an idea on
this it has
become completely obvious that the
dissidents in america
are trump supporters the punks
are trump supporters yeah man the people
that johnny rotten dude
the people that do diy media
production audio trump supporters we're
out there this is something that i did
when i was a kid
we did raves back then in the 90s right
we broke into warehouses and like dj'd
and played crazy music and did a bunch
of drugs
and i was a rebel and i've always been a
rebel and i'm seeing this now
more people seeing the fact that biden
and tifa bill
it's the establishment you can't there's
no denying the fact that they are the
establishment now
with the corporations the names on the
streets the backing of the government
the nba
all this they are the they are now the
establishment
and good branding for trump is to scoop
up those disaffected people be like
you're a punk
we're punks we are insurgents dude
within
the united states trump is an insurgent
johnny rotten johnny rotten you saw
johnny ryan right i did it was sad to
see him in such a state
physically he was like really good yeah
but yeah dude with maga full on because
he sees it and anybody who's
involved in punk politics sees it let me
let me tell you something okay
you guys you know you know sex pistols
yeah sex pistols oh gee pong like
johnny rotten yep he was a lead singer
wasn't he oh yeah
and and this guy came out and he was
seen wearing a maga shirt
and then people asked him like you're
voting for trump he's like of course
and he voted for clinton in 2016. he
said he voted for hillary clinton 2016
obama obama
now he's voting trump and he says
because biden's not capable of being the
president
and the economy's like you can't ignore
it and i'm like that's extremely
rational and
normal point to be made the funny thing
is you know ricky gervais brought it up
in one of his live streams and it was
really funny he was like oh
johnny rotten like why why would johnny
rotten wear a maga shirt apparently you
can't do that or said maga hat
he's like well unless you're an aging
punk trying to agitate people
and i laugh at that too because at least
ricky's got a fun
attitude about it but i think ricky's
wrong you look they look at johnny
rotten the people who are
you know like ricky gervais who are you
know having a good time still willing to
have a laugh and he thinks
johnny rotten's just trying to make
everybody angry and you listen to johnny
rotten he's like well the economy was
really good under
you know donald trump and i have to
recognize that and you know joe biden
just doesn't seem to have it i'm like
that's like a normal point to me man
that's not educating anybody exactly but
someone someone posted a photo
of sid vicious wearing a swastika
t-shirt and so he was the original
singer
yeah and it's like i don't think these
people know what punk punk is
yeah you know what i mean yeah so like
when i grew up with pong
and i i i look i'm not going to pretend
to know what punk is because apparently
there's so many different punks and
everyone thinks
like libertarians yeah exactly yes lousy
punks they ruined punk
exactly but like what i was told when i
was growing up when i was looking at
punk music and i was skating was that
it was basically anti-establishment
anti-authoritarian
the reason that like these guys there
was they would dye their hair
shave their like the sides of their head
make their hair look weird and wear
weird clothes
was to be as offensive and shocking as
possible to the squares to the normies
so yes sid vicious would wear a swastika
t-shirt because he's like he wanted you
to get angry and
and he wanted to challenge what you
would be comfortable in he wanted to
shock your you to your core that's not
what punk is today
it's like been perfectly co-opted
there's this really funny cartoon
of this woman wearing like uh a jean
vest
and she's got like a purple mohawk or
something and she's like
you're not punk unless you support black
lives matter
and i'm like and then there's another
funny one where it's like
you're not it was a mockery of it you're
not punk unless your opinions align with
every major multinational billion dollar
corporation
exactly real pump doesn't it'll get
banned that's the problem
yeah cause like i would be swearing and
wearing a shirt with the koala giving
the finger right now
if if i could you probably you probably
can do that yeah i might wear the koala
shirts someday do it
i mean dude i mean one day that's going
to be offensive what you're wearing and
they're going to go back in time and
delete the video the boards take over
and then they'll see that they're going
to they're going to rewrite the prime
directive
elon musk is going to neural link
everybody then we're going to start
talking about how the borg was writing
star trek and then they're going to ban
your shirt i think
punk is real it's just so dissuaded by
um
social media it lives on currently
in social media this is the punk spirit
this is the punk spirit right now
diy challenge the facts challenge the
establishment
create your own narrative build your own
space have your own community
fu i'm not going to listen to you
remember oh my god i'm just having
flashbacks rage against machines
it's making me so sad because thinking
about them they are now the machine
and no no it's rage on behalf of them
right oh there you go that's what it is
and i still listen to one song over and
over on my workout list you know f you i
won't do what you tell me
i won't do what you tell me you i won't
do what you tell me
i mean that's a vibe man you know the
american spirit a lot of it is
the mood you tell me to do something i
do the opposite
yeah yeah you get in my face you demand
i raise my fist i'll flick you off
and that's there must be an insidious
reason for you
being the authoritarian that comes from
that lack of that natural distrust for
authority because
and that's trump dude that's why trump
says the crazy things that he does
that's why he says
that's
are you saying donald trump is punk rock
definitely hundred percent yeah
100 percent this guy wearing a suit yes
a businessman
yes punk rock he's punk rock 100 to
we used to wear suits like yeah like
dress pants suits long sleeve buttons
with collars we used to go skate and we
would put on suits and it's not
for real like not the clothing we would
skate wearing we'll get like thrift
store suits and we would go skate with a
tie and a suit because like beastie boys
because era but you know you know what
it was like when my friends were doing
it
and when i was doing it it was basically
like skateboarding was becoming
mainstream
and popular and so to be
the antithesis of this was to wear a
suit now nice because it's like mtv had
a show and the dudes are wearing the
the same kind of clothes and now they
started marketing you know they started
making the clothes
that were like pre-ripped or pre-frayed
or whatever
and so it was like my jeans were ruined
because i was skating and was
you know scraping my you know falling
down then they started selling
pre-ruined jeans
we went to thrift store put on suits
right they started wearing it it was fun
i would love to see
clips of that you should recreate it
that'd be amazing i mean that was a
trend back in like so funny the early
2000s with skateboarders wearing suits
because it was like
so here's the thing about punk and
subcultures in general subcultures in
general
have a life cycle to them they start off
in the dark corners and they get a
little bit more popular and then
eventually the mainstream co-ops them
right and then it takes away all their
bite
okay and so what we're seeing now with
social media and technology
is there's no way to co-opt it you're
not gonna be co-opted tim
you're not going to just get swallowed
up your voice isn't going to get just
put into the din with the rest of the
establishment social media
provides a place for for dissidents to
actually
have a life cycle where they don't get
co-opted by the mainstream
i firmly believe and i was talking about
this with the guy who's a an
ethnomusicologist as a matter of fact he
studies dissident music scenes
that there isn't one right now in the
united states there isn't a dissonant
music scene
and that energy didn't go away it lives
on right now
maga social media have you heard what uh
like the the it's like the the guy
started bad religion i think
i can't remember exactly what he was
saying but he was talking about like
black lives matter and the establishment
being punk
but they wrote a song i think this was
bad religion about this
it was an alt-right like recruitment
song yeah it was bad religion
they wrote a song and it was called the
kids are alt-right or whatever oh yeah
and when the song came out i was hearing
from these lefties that is it's a punk
song that's supposed to be against the
alt-right
but the song's pro alt-right like the
the lyrics are like everybody needs
somebody come join the party and i'm
like
this is not critical in any capacity
they're not insulting them
they're literally telling people it's
fun come hang out like
that's weird berkeley super weird i
don't know about that
i know that the dissident energy that i
grew up with that i've fostered and
channeled as a teen is
living on today i used to have a studio
in my basement making music
and an old mac doing scenes and writing
like little
articles to hand out at parties and
whatever what am i doing today i got a
studio in my basement
i'm writing online i'm doing twitter and
blogs like it's the same vibe same mood
sorry
yeah that's right i was i was reading
something interesting where it was like
this teacher asked
uh his students how many of them thought
that if they were alive during slavery
that they would have opposed slavery
he was like imagine you you know it's
the era of slavery slaver's alive right
now how many of you would oppose it
they'll raise their hand
and he says okay now each and every one
of you i want you to name something
you've done
that has gone against the establishment
has been extremely unpopular would get
you fired from your job kicked out of
school
or grounded for life and none of them
had any nothing to say
and he's and he said during that era
slavery was the establishment
acceptable norm and those that opposed
it were the fringe
anti-establishment weirdos and the
people freeing the slaves were
criminals and the slaves that were like
they were sending out people to catch
them
he's like each and every one of you
following the establishment listening to
your popular music
you are doing exactly the opposite of
what you think you would be doing
sweet i would have been an abolitionist
that's right yeah probably
i think it's funny because like people
have tried saying that about me yeah all
right
thank goodness people people try
claiming that
me and a bunch of other you know
moderate or you know
freedom-minded individuals would be the
ones and i'm like
it's the exact opposite right you're the
ones that are screaming in a woman's
face while raising your fist demand she
raised her fist with you
there's no there's no comparable
movement right you're like on the right
for that no you've got the creepy weirdo
you know white supremacist types
but you know you know what i realized
too creepy you know why i think there's
an e like the left describes a very
obvious group and the right doesn't
because the right as we describe it is
more individualist right so you have a
bunch of disparate individuals and
groups that don't unify on any ideas
right the left they're collectivists so
they all
form up hive and then agree on all these
things right
social justice economic policy for the
most part you got dirt bag left and you
got woke left but you know
right and then i guess the alt-right is
kind of kind of awoke
right or something another economic
policy is left i don't know whatever
dude the alt-right there's nothing about
it today is different than the alt-right
a decade ago
the alt-right a decade ago was like
neo-conservative warm-up there wasn't an
all-right
there it was the neo-cons no it wasn't
the all-right didn't exist the new
conservatives it was like
all right specifically known as white
nationalists regular conservatives
didn't though but let's not get into
that it didn't it didn't write it at
first
no it did i mean this is a big mistake a
lot of a lot of people
on the the new right as they call it
make they
assumed alt-right meant alternative to
the right
when it was actually coined by white
nationalists in the first place
yes that is accurate yeah yeah i made
the same assumption error
early part of 2015. yup i was like all
right oh that sounds cool but it's not
no
wait delete delete delete it's not cool
at all
what is this awful awful old ideology oh
no i don't like that yeah i don't like
that at all but the but
the intersectional left the same thing
yeah no doubt thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you